[موسيقى]
أه خلال الربع الأول من هذا العام
كان لدينا حوالي 9200
رخصة تجارية دولية جديدة صادرة في السعودية أي
أكثر من السنوات الست الماضية مجتمعة ،
هناك قدر كبير من
الاهتمام التجاري الدولي في المملكة العربية السعودية بسبب
رؤية 2030 والتحول الاقتصادي
تتصارع الشركات مع بعضها البعض للحصول على
مساحات مكتبية والتركيز الآن على
الدرجة الأفضل في فئتها المكتبية
[تصفيق] إن
التطورات مثل حي الملك عبد الله
المالي مشغولة بالكامل ،
ولم يتبق مكان وفي آخر
12 شهرًا زادت إيجارات المكاتب  14 في
المائة إلى حوالي 1700 ريال للمتر المربع ،
لذا فإن أي زيادة طفيفة أو زيادة مستمرة
في الطلب ستؤدي بالتأكيد إلى
زيادة أسعار المكاتب أكثر
وسيستغرق العرض بضع سنوات
قبل أن يأتي
[موسيقى]